I was like yeah sounds like a great
idea
so I pile into a car filled with
strangers and headed out to find Santa
Claus what could go wrong
all right best friends in the world
that's gonna absolutely love them please
give it up for mr. Steve Rannazzisi
everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
I love hi I love it people think that I
actually have a problem with pot but I
don't remember their names so it
doesn't matter to me doesn't affect me
at all but I don't like traveling upon
me to communion you got to travel all
over the place I'm not good going
through the airport I'm paranoid enough
as it is
I'm usually high on the way to the
airport so the last thing I need is to
be my own drug mule going through TSA
worrying about getting busted you know
last time I did it I already told me
just put some joints in an air-tight
thing and put it in your underwear
they've these little airtight containers
I put the joints in the airtight thing
and I put it in my underwear and as I'm
going through TSA it starts to slip down
my pants legs and now I'm like oh boy if
it falls out this is it so I'm dead
legging it the rest of the way through
the airport it's like please people are
like can we get the man with cerebral
palsy wheelchair please please so I
don't do that anymore but luckily for me
I played a character named Kevin on the
TV show called the league for a couple
of years yeah thank you
and the show's got a huge stomach
demographic so I'm taking care of a lot
of heavy handshakes on the road
everybody wants to smoke pot with Kevin
everybody oh it's Kevin let's
smoke no one gives any shits
about Steve in the home Steve is just a
vessel to take drunk and stoned Kevin
wherever he has to go but this pot it
doesn't come free you know you think oh
we're just gonna get free pot on the
road no there's a price you pay yeah
awkward conversations dealing with
people who aren't used to smoke pot I
smoke a ton of pot I'm used
to it but you will get people who just
smoke so much that they just smoke
themselves onto the spectrum you know
they just they smoke themselves special
don't just stare at you and you got to
deal with these people you're you're
among strangers you don't want to be
rude so you're just like you're hanging
out with them and they'll just stand
there lingering staring at you you know
introducing themselves multiple times
asking questions answering questions
nobody else asks
just weird you try not to hate a man I
think our time here is done they don't
pick up on any social cues so you have
to deal with these people I call these
people pot blockers okay they block the
fun for everybody else we all want to be
fun on pot and you're ruining of course
so I stay away from the pot blockers and
now recently I was in Nashville and
after my first show is doing stand-up
after the first show talking to people
hanging out after smoking joints with
the staff
some fans hanging out and it was real
dirt weed so I'm not usually a good
photos like hey I don't wanna be an
asshole but does anyone have any better
weed but this you know like I didn't
come to Nashville for this weed and
they were like oh let's go to Santis and
we can I got some friends we could smoke
pot there and I was like yeah
sounds like a great idea
so I pile into a car filled with
strangers and headed out to find Santa
Claus what could possibly go wrong guys
what could go wrong and as I'm dry
you're driving were smoking more of this
weed and I'm starting get paranoid
because I'm seeing less and less
civilization and more and more making a
murderer you know I don't know if we
passed Steven Avery's house but I think
I saw and now my host I'm getting
nerves because I'm like this is it I
know what I'm in the middle of I'm being
kidnapped I'm in the middle of Beacon
this is kidnapping 101 this is the first
thing you would teach it Hey you would
be like hey buddy hey you you like
puppies yeah my friend stand has got all
the puppies he's got him getting the van
he's got him in a bucket at home I'll
give you one so I'm nervous and then
also I see one of the passengers with
goes oh we're here we're here we reached
it this is Santa's pub and that's where
we were going Santa's pub Santa's pub is
the number one dive bar in Nashville and
it's not really have you been there
before it's I mean it's a it's not
really a bar as much as it is a
double-wide trailer
that they tried to convert into a bar
and just shoved it into the middle of
the woods it looks like Santa Claus went
through a really bad divorce in the 70s
and this is all mrs. Claus would give
him just take your shanty shack and sit
in the woods fat man here's a great
example of the clientele that goes to
the Santa's pub beer is one dollar water
is two dollars yes so any place think
about in any place where beer is less
expensive than water and you're not in
Flint Michigan you're gonna have a good
time so I was like it let's go into
this Santa's hobble we walk inside and
they do karaoke every night
karaoke seven nights a week cuz it's
Nashville and everyone can sing
everybody they take it seriously
everyone's hanging out they're singing
they're getting their songs and his dirt
read must have started kicking in
because now I'm in the book and I'm like
what I'm already picking out my third
song I've got one in two I've got I'm
too sexy
followed by pink Cadillac in my mind
this is I would have taken the house
down with pink Cadillac it all said
everyone went nuts because that's when
Santa showed up the guy that owns the
place and his pub and he was with his
buddy and this Santa Claus he takes it
very seriously okay this is not ironic
Santa he's got the beard the hair all
white big belly
except he puts his own little twist on
it okay he looks like Santa Claus gave
up all that Christmas nonsense 20 years
ago and started making meth in the woods
with his friends
still rough around the edge of his Santa
Claus I was fixated on I couldn't
believe but everybody else was so
psyched they didn't care about Santa
they cared about his friend they were
like holy he's here I'm like who
that guy is the greatest unknown singer
in Nashville I'm like really the guy in
pajama pants Tevas and a t-shirt in the
middle of the woods no no that guy's got
a voice of an angel I'm like oh sure I
heard that's how Springsteen started out
too but girl you had to hear him sing
him well when does he go on they go well
he smokes pot with Santa around the back
of the trailer and then he goes on
whenever he feels like it and all I
heard was smokes pot with Santa and I
beeline for the dorm I was like
I'm going to five East
thirty seconds later I am slopping
through the snow in Jordans around the
back of this double-wide trailer
pitch-black I can't see anything at all
I'm going as Santa Santa Santa here
finally to go over and I see three
people I see Santa Claus the angel voice
guy and a third person who was holding
court that guy was in the middle of the
conversation talking and I walked up to
them right and they must have heard me
coming because they they stopped talking
and they were like they were shocked I
guess that's the way you would be if a
stranger came tumbling out of the woods
and interrupted your conversation so I
didn't want to see him weird so I just
was like okay I'm just gonna introduce
myself so I walk up to Santa and I was
like hey Santa hey my name is Steve and
I'm super excited to meet you and I
really love your place and he just
stared at me like does this
who think I'm the real Santa Claus he
probably thought like is he gonna sit on
my lap and tell me he wants a ten-speed
for Christmas next so I was like oh okay
strike one so I turned to the second guy
the angel voice guy and I'm like hey man
my name is Steve nice to meet you
III heard you can heard you got a great
voice you going on tonight and he's like
yup and now it's like angel voice just
left me for dead
and I was like strike two so I turned to
the third guy and before I could say
anything he goes hey I'm Bob and I was
like oh okay cool all right Bob look at
us what a crew we got out here we got
crystal meth Kringle Susan Boyle Bob
nice let's smoke pot except this Bob
wasn't any all Bob all right this was
just a run-of-the-mill Bob you run into
this guy his real name was Robert James
Ritchie
does that ring a bell to anyone yeah you
may know him by his better-known name
Kid Rock yes I interrupted Kid Rock's
conversation and he wasn't
psyched
he was staring at me like I was Tommy
Lee's dick just like what the is
this guy
the hell are just I'm starting to put
all this together I was like I
interrupted their conversation I'm
asking questions I'm lingering holy
I'm the pop blocker now how do I
get out of this but I do I didn't want
to get out of it I did I wanted to say
that cuz how many times in your life are
you gonna get an opportunity to smoke
pot with Santa Claus and kid
Rock I mean if you asked me if you asked
me in 1994 what do you want for
christmas smoked pot with Santa and Kid
Rock and maybe instead of angel boys it
would have been the Josie guy
the little guy that Kid Rock used to
hang out with me with and read it over
[Applause]
so I was like I'm gonna stall and try to
wait for someone to pull out some sticky
icky and let's get this party going so
everyone is still staring at me like I
am a science project so I just go okay
what do I do next so I turn to Bobby
Hill hey Bob are you here to go on
tonight and he goes what do you think
and I just went okay and then all of a
sudden thank goodness out of the front
patio you hear someone go hey Kevin we
got more wheat and I was like oh that's
me guys I gotta get out of here and I
turned and started Shane slopping my way
back around the front and I Oh as I got
about 10 feet away
I heard angel voice go he doesn't even
know his own name and they started
laughing and I was like oh this is a low
lease is a true low
so I got up front to the front patio and
everyone was like hey did you get to see
Santa Claus did you find him I'm like
yeah yeah I found Santa Claus and you
could have told me Kid Rock was around
the corner - and they're all
Kid Rock oh yeah
Kid Rock's right there he's around the
corner oh you Kid Rock say I go
listen I understand that I am a known
liar but Kid Rock
I understand trust me I get it
but I promise you Kid Rock is a hundred
feet away around the corner and they all
went for him and I used that to slowly
back my way and I got into a cab and I
got the out of there and I'm dry
the cab drivers driving home and I'm you
know you start to replay what you like
oh what have I done
this is not good and I'm like how do I
make up for this how do I make this
better and I oh I text my friend Chris
Porter Chris Porter comedian very funny
comedian here's also great friends with
Kid Rock and I texted him and I was like
dude I think I just met Kid Rock and it
didn't go well at all and just please
let him know that I am NOT mentally
challenged and I went to bed feeling
much better about myself and I woke up
in the morning to a text message from
Chris Porter it was a screengrab and he
had cut and pasted exactly what I had
sent to him and sent it to Kid Rock and
Kid Rock wrote back I you not on my
sons lives yes he is period and I can't
say I disagree thank you guys very much
[Applause]